منظومه التكامس تعرف بانها صواريخ
باليستيه بعيده المدى موجهه وشديده الدقه
يصل مداها الى نحو 300 كيلومتر ويمكن
اطلاقها من منصات متحركه كراجمات الصواريخ
هايمارس هذا الصاروخ مصمم لمهاجمه الاهداف
الاستراتيجيه كالمطارات ومواقع صواريخ
ارجوا وقوات المدفعيه ومناطق الامداد
ومجموعات القياده او نقاط الاتصالات اما
عن حركته الجويه فان ارتفاع صاروخ التكامز
يتراوح من 50 الى 65 كيلو مترا ويسمح هذا
الارتفاع للصاروخ بتجنب معظم انظمه الدفاع
ارض جو مع الحفاظ على الدقه اللازمه
للضربات
اما عن سرعته فتصلوا الى حوالي ثلاثه الاف
وسبعمائه كيلو متر في الساعه ويبلغ طوله
اربعه امتار ووزن راسه الحربي بين 160
و560 كيلو جراما اضافه الى ان تصميم
الصاروخ الذي يعمل بالوقود الصلب يجعله
مناسبا للعمل في بيئات متنوعه
وتعتمد صواريخ اتكامز على راس حربي ينشا
عنه انفجار تعادل شدته القوه التفجيريه
لنحو 28
كيلو جراما من ماده تي ان تي وتواجه عن
طريق الملاحه وبمساعده نظام تحديد المواقع
جي بي اس
هذا الصاروخ موجود لدى القوات البريه
الامريكيه منذ عام
1990 واطلق منه
450 صاروخا خلال غزو العراق عام
2003 وفيما بعد عام 2015 اطلق اكثر من
50060 صاروخا من نظام التكانز في حروب عده